[Music]
thank you
on this edition of The Sky News Daily
some of the stories which defined 2022
and the way in which they might shape
our lives in future over five special
episodes we will be covering Politics
the economy the royal family climate
change but on this one Russia's invasion
of Ukraine uh the Chinese Chinese
president's grip on par and of course
the struggle for Freedom around the
world as you can tell if you are
watching uh sitting across from me our
International Affairs editor Dominic
wycon and Dominic 2022 a year to
remember a year to forget in so many
ways I suspect you've been racking up
the air miles yeah I've traveled more
this year than I've ever tried before it
was way more than I've been at home so
it's been uh
it's been an extraordinary year and
pretty Sinister at times and deeply
worrying and I think we'll look back on
this year as the year that changed
everything probably the most
transformational year or consequential
year since the I mean arguably since the
second world war because it's
it's a year it's not just a Ukraine war
but obviously you know we now NATO
effectively is fighting a war with
Russia with everything but troops and
obviously it's not over yet
um and the consequences the implications
of that are enormous for the future
however however it ends up but I think
it's it's what's happening in China as
well and between China and America that
has huge implications you now have in
China a kind of new emperor Xi Jinping
who is confirmed now for a third term an
unprecedented third term in office he's
a man with a vision and he sees China's
Destiny is taking over the world
effectively or taking up its its its
natural place he said he thinks as a
kind of superpower lead in the world and
and I said the battle lines are drawn
between uh the West they're being fought
over in Ukraine but also diplomatically
in geopolitically between the west and
China and that has huge consequences for
the future so yeah it's been an
extraordinary year it will be
fascinating to see what comes next but
let's let's start by reflecting on 2022
and of course one of the biggest stories
of the year at that conflict that why
let's call it what it is not a special
military operation between Russia and
Ukraine from where we started the year
to where we ended I mean just just give
us an idea of the Dynamics that we have
seen in this conflict over the past 12
months well it started from a moment a
point of complete surprise really um I
left my home at six in the morning to go
to Moscow
um not expecting the war to happen and I
was like many people saying you know all
the Russian analysts I spoke to said
there's no way that Putin will launch
this war it would be mad for him to do
so genuinely because I have to ask you
on that people with that because it's
difficult I almost forgot that the war
started you know within the past 12
months but were people were people
genuinely shocked at this at this given
the huge build up that there was on the
borders of Ukraine yeah well exactly
there were tens of thousands of Russian
troops but every Russian analyst you
spoke to said it would be mad for him to
invade the few said he might but if he
does it'll it'll be over in a week or
two it'll have to be because otherwise
he'll fall from power so all their
predictions of um have not come true and
the people who did get it right with the
military and the intelligence agencies
and journalists working close for them
because particularly when they started
seeing blood stocks being sent to these
thousands of troops they they thought
it's got to be imminent but there was a
real sense of shock when it happened and
within I think the first sort of week or
so when I was in Moscow off The Invasion
started I interviewed Andre cortunov who
was a foreign policy analyst very close
to the Kremlin kind of a foreign policy
advisor to to the Kremlin and he was in
a deep sense of shock he said because it
talked for a while in sort of foreign
policy very dry geopolitical analysis
but I said you know that's you the
analyst was a human being how do you
feel and the color of the ma slipped and
he said I'm just so depressed I I didn't
think this would happen I'm depressed
everyone around me is depressed there
should be in the people in the Kremlin
depressed as as well so for him it came
as a complete surprise because
it just didn't make sense geopolitically
for Vladimir Putin to do this but
obviously he was operating under a
different rationale to what we thought
he was well everything the one thing we
can see is that it has not gone as
Vladimir Putin intended no absolutely
yeah it's it's I think he was under the
impression that it would be over fairly
quickly that a sort of lightning
Blitzkrieg operation would uh take Kiev
using paratroopers and sort of a
lightning Armored Strike underestimated
the ukrainians didn't they he did and I
think he underestimated that but also
the support the West would give the
ukrainians it was a fair amount of
Special Forces I think support for the
ukrainians as well going on there but
yeah what he expected he was advised by
his intelligence agencies was was that
the a lot of ukrainians would come out
and and welcome them as liberators
um and that his forces would fight more
effectively than they have and you have
to bear in mind that he has uh spent a
lot of money on on his military but a
lot of that's gone into the back pockets
of the sort of military oligarchs if you
like around him so they've had to say
this money you're spending is is money
well spent
not selling them there spending the
money on their Villas in France or their
or their Yachts or whatever so at the
beginning they were saying also all the
way through um you know it's it's going
well you know this the military is
performing as we said it would but
obviously the the country was was true
and so the attempt to decapitate the
Ukrainian regime failed and now we're
stuck into they've had to pull back from
Kiev we're stuck into this kind of
artillery War which is devastating in
the East and a gradual process of the
Russians retreating in the face of this
determined spirited Onslaught by the
ukrainians and we have seen a number of
atrocities there has been an awful lot
of Bloodshed and Ukraine song there has
and there's been you know as you say
atrocities committed on both sides um
reporting the ukrainians thought to have
executed a few people a few Russians
summarily but most of them carried out
by the Russians and horrendous
atrocities in butcher to the north of
Kiev but uh rapes Mass Graves found and
rape being used as a weapon of War we've
heard most recently from president
zielinski's wife the First Lady Ukraine
so there's there's a sense the Russians
are using this deliberately to
intimidate the enemy or have been but
also a sense of a lack of command and
control a lack of breakdown of
discipline and complete disarray and
Chaos in the in the Russian rank so much
so that you know the Russian Rank and
file have been so frustrated by their
commanders at times they've taken things
into their own hands and at one point
remember a Russian Commander was run
over by the tank of some of his own
troops so there's that disarray has been
the kind of Hallmark the characteristic
of the Russian military operation until
General Armageddon Sarah Vikram was
appointed and he's brought a new sense
of discipline and Order and a better
sort of military logic which means we're
now seeing the Russians holding the line
um and more of a stalemate emerging
north of Crimea and in the East some
people had predicted that the sanctions
would see the Russians going to change
that hasn't happened the Russian economy
hasn't completely evaporated their
Central Bank has done some decent work
but there has been one significant
consequence of this conflict of course
which is the the global impact in terms
of prices and not just not just of
course in in terms of energy yeah I mean
the the grain situation we went to
Odessa on on the the docks of Odessa
there were I forget I think it was a
quarter of a million tons of grain there
was a a ship that hadn't left Harbor
which was due to go to ban for Egypt and
it had in its enough grain we worked out
to feed 300 000 Egyptians for a year
right so that was a huge amount of grain
trapped that now that grain's getting
out but the economic impact has been as
you said it's been it's it's globally
been felt uh and it's been devastating
it's led to inflation fuel prices going
up it's destabilized the whole global
economy if it goes on for another year
the estimates are somewhere between two
and a half trillion and three trillion
dollars the world economy so it's been
devastating for the for the world but
also devastating for for Russia and
Ukraine obviously a huge amount of
Civilian infrastructure destroyed in
Ukraine and on the Russian side a
massive brain drain and
um a sense that there regime is safe for
now is intact that has control but there
is maneuvering going on in the Kremlin
there is a sense I think that that
Putin's not his position isn't secure
forever and he can't do this
indefinitely so that raises any
questions for next year what what about
questions about NATO's status and all of
this I mean has it truly been
strengthened yet we have seen countries
acting in concert I mean who knows where
the Ukrainian conflict would be right
now if NATO countries had not provided
material in the in the way in which they
had but but I do wonder you know Crimea
was in 2014 you know this was a problem
that that some analysts presumably did
see coming at some point NATO hasn't
proved to be the bulwark against kind of
Russian expansionism that it was
supposed to be yeah yes and no I mean
yeah
absolutely but bear in mind that for six
years since Trump's election we have
been uh fretting over the face of the
Western Alliance of the world the
post-war World Order because Trump had
no faith in it and was impatient with it
and thought the idea of multilateral
organizations was something he had no
time for and there was a sense that the
disunity that but also the divisions and
the alliance meant that it was
on borrowed time but it's it's risen to
the challenge the biggest challenge it's
faced since the second world war coming
up with a United position on sanctions
on on action against Russia and that
failed to deter Putin and it's it's
managed to continue keeping that
solidarity and unity together during the
war um supporting uh Ukraine so you know
the Western Lights has held up
reasonably well in terms of solidarity
and unity but it hasn't worked it hasn't
it has not stopped the Russian invasion
and we now face a kind of logistical
problem which is where Ukraine is using
up Western supplied Munitions so fast
that actually the West is not producing
them fast enough to keep up and we're
seeing a kind of almond arms race
between Russia desperately trying to use
its industry to create enough weapons to
fight the ukrainians and vice versa so
yes stresses and strains but yeah I mean
it was an intelligence failure in the
sense that it wasn't prepared for enough
it wasn't seen coming but actually I
think diplomatically the alliance has
done better than was expected
simple question and but I suspect with
that with a rather complicated answer do
you think we will actually get an end to
the conflict in 2023 I mean I think the
dangerous thing for people like me and
you so students I mean if you look back
a year ago anybody sit in the studio
they would not have predicted sustained
unrest on the streets of Tehran they
wouldn't have predicted the biggest
unrest in China for 30 years since they
wouldn't have predicted we've got used
to this war but there's no way a year
ago we would have thought the wall could
have carried on and killed tens of
thousands of people and Putin's still
being in Paris so it's you know it's a
Fool's errand isn't it I think what we
can say we can look out for certain
things and I think with with the Ukraine
war Putin's best chance of not losing is
dividing Europe it's going to be a very
tough winter for the ukrainians but also
for Europe and those divisions that
disunity in Europe is also is already
like under enormous pressure so
countries like Italy who are
economically going to be most affected
by the War I think we might see them
break ranks and pushing for negotiations
UK trains position and the British
governments is is that any concessions
to Putin will just give them more more
of a foothold to continue his action
later on it needs to be beaten he needs
to be beaten decisively so he he can try
and divide the Allies I think the other
thing to look for is what's happening in
the Kremlin because you know he looks
secure in power but we are seeing
various people around who are
maneuvering like pregocian producing
Chef his nickname is he runs and and
controls the Vagner group we've seen
people like him maneuvering a bit and I
think we might see more of that so watch
out what's happening with Europe but
also what's happening in the Kremlin and
of course that relationship with China
but let's let's focus on China itself
though and its president she
um getting a third term I mean he is now
essentially you know president and
perpetuity isn't it he is he's
effectively the emperor and it's
interesting because you've got um him
and China and you've got Putin in Russia
who's effectively a kind of Czar for the
21st century
going back to sort of an old form an old
model of rule he's yeah XI Jin King is
for ever since dung Xiaoping in the in
the 80s you've had a Chinese leader
that's given up after two terms and
that's allowed the Chinese leadership to
kind of renew itself and and learn from
the past and be more pragmatic now he's
very different he's he's now entrenched
in power he sees him he sees the destiny
of China he saw Mao as the man who
United China under the Communist dong
Xiaoping made it richer again and he's
the man that's going to take it to its
its Destiny which is effectively a
superpower
leading the world and reforming the
world order in China's image so
basically in a more autocratic lines and
that is a direct threat to the worst so
he he wants to establish the world in a
very Chinese way to be autocratic and
the West is pushing from continuing some
liberal values that it's that's operated
on under the second world war so that
sure that's a massive Titanic struggle
for the future it is particularly when
you have such a dissatisfied populace
and and a huge populace that that could
well turn I mean in terms of the covert
restrictions because that that we
suspect is the the well is the root
cause for much of the outbreak of
protest the fact that they have had to
step away from their zero covered policy
doesn't scream that they're in complete
control no it doesn't and and they are
under pressure from that and I think
that the danger for them is that they
are going to have to lift the pressure
fulfill it a bit because it's led to
this
the biggest unrest we've seen for 30
years you know for that to happen when I
was there in 2004 to six was unheard of
talking to Tom Chester who's his left
who's you know he obviously very
frustrated for him he didn't see this
but for 30 years we've not seen Chinese
come out in the streets and demand Xi
Jinping to stand down it's unheard of so
it's led to massive pressure for change
that could lead to
um a relaxation of covert rules that
could then lead to more infections it's
inevitably will because they've been
told by the government you don't need to
get a vaccine all the secondary
importance because we've got this under
control particularly the older people so
if you leave if it leads to a massive
covered infections that could lead to
more unrest and I think that will be a
challenge for the Chinese government are
we seeing however the West the West
perhaps starting to be you know slightly
more bullish towards China towards sheet
I mean I think of Russia sunak
identifying China as you know as perhaps
the biggest problem we're gonna have to
deal with in 2023. yes it's fine I think
the West has finally worked out that the
idea that we sort of left the cold war
with which was the the Battle of idea
years have been one and that the the way
forward for any country was to be more
capitalist to be more free more
democratic and it's only a matter of
time before countries like China would
would follow the Western path that has
deluded Western leaders you know for for
decades and it's it's clearly not the
way China is heading and so that Penny
dropped the idea of George Osborne
talking about there's some Golden Era
between British Chinese relations that
looks very nice we're away from that now
we've moved on from that yeah so yeah so
and what we're seeing now is a conscious
uncoupling which is a rather sort of
clunky phrase but it's it's what
economists use to describe what American
China are doing which is China's
becoming more self-sufficient America is
to America trying to build its own
semiconductor industry for instance
placing sanctions on Chinese technology
um it's it's a natural I think outcome
of the covert pandemic as well where we
realize that these long thousands of
miles Supply chains weren't not can't be
relied on anymore
um and it's a it's a new order it's you
know what we have in the past is a
virtue cycle of China lending to America
the Chinese consumers buying Chinese
stuff and that was that was helping fuel
the Chinese economic transformation
that's gone now and it's a it's a very
different future and it it's problematic
if it's not managed very carefully
because if you have that kind of
division there's more room for
misunderstanding there's more room for
confrontation particularly over Taiwan
where we will see in 2023. uh Dom you
just take a breather just for a second
um after the break we will be turning
our attention to Iran and of course the
death of Masa amini
welcome back to this special edition of
The Sky News Daily our International
Affairs editor Dominic weinkorn still
here taking us through I mean his choice
of the stories uh from the preceding 12
months and we have to talk about Iran
don't we don't because I we were saying
about China just before the break that
you know we the unprecedented
um scenes of of descent similar in Iran
explain how we got to that point well
it's been building up for a long while
and the regime has become more and more
discouraging because it's not delivering
what the Iranians Iranians want uh
economically and they have felt more and
more repressed by it and it's it's a
Theocratic regime that goes back to
1979. the Iranians kind of feel the
world is is leaving them behind but the
spark was this death of Amenia Kurdish
young Kurdish woman who was taken in um
to custody by the morality police the
guidance for sure I think it's called
because she wasn't wearing a hijab a
headscar if you go to Iran all women
have to wear them some of them flout the
rules by wearing a very little bit of
cloth just at the back of their heads
you can see so there's there's that kind
of symbolic protest but if you don't
wear it you can get taken and she was
taken to custody and she was so badly
beaten she died in custody and that was
a spark and it led to these upright
these uprisings and process across the
country across the country we should see
it wasn't just localized in Tehran or
something but yeah the big difference
between the unrest now and what what
we've seen in the past is it's been
localized in the past this time it's
it's United the Shia the the
um the Kurds just ordinary Iranians but
the big difference really is that it's
been led by the women and that's sort of
you know Across the Nation and it's not
going away and the regimes used
everything they can you know normally
they use brought foot Brute Force to go
out and shoots people and they also take
people in and they also threaten their
families which can be very effective in
stopping young people something we've
covered on on The Daily with a couple of
members of our forensics and data uh
Team looked at someone being take well
be being shot dead on the street for no
apparent reason and the further we dug
into it there genuinely was none bar
striking fear Into the Heart of ordinary
Iranians yeah it's a very very brutal
regime and the problem for them is that
it's not working this time around so
they're kind of scratch on the head
saying well we're shooting them we're
taking them and we're pulling them that
we're threats and giving them as well
and exactly the narrative so they are
they are keeping this this hard line but
whatever they do it's not deterring the
process which so if you talk to some
Western diplomats you know Iran well
they say the regime is finished it's
just a matter of time it could be really
months even years but other years
doesn't sound Finnish to me well it's
it's on borrowed time they would say but
yeah others would say well look if you
look at the Maduro regime they kind of
set the model which actually they kind
of learned for their owners as well but
basically if you have a security
apparatus that you support and you fund
and you cost it and you may feel that
their their loss is in with yours then
you can last indefinitely so I think but
it's a great question of a time really I
think is is can can these forces
popular forces Prevail against these
repressive governments run by corrupt
old men I think the problem for the
Iranian government is is it's not going
away but it doesn't have a leadership it
doesn't have any sort of focus the
protest which is a strength and a
weakness so at the moment it's become
stalemate but it's ongoing I suspect
then looking ahead to 2023 descent and
the way in which it might arise and the
way in which it might be suppressed is
something you'll be keeping a close eye
on yeah because I mean 2022 has been as
we were saying it's been setting the
East and the West against each other a
Chasm opening up between East and the
west and it's really been the story of
of autocracy against democracy and
that's been at a geopolitical level
leaders against leaders but also on the
street so the Chinese the Iranians and
the Russians when they able to come out
in protest demanding more freedom and
more democracy and a raid against that
is is technology that the Chinese in
particular are developing for instance
if you go to Shanghai and you cross the
streets on a red Crossing uh your face
will get recognized with facial recogn
technology and you'll automatically be
fined on your WeChat bank account or
really yeah so you don't even need to
know it oh dear right but and I suspect
it gets rather more Insidious than that
yeah so that's that that's the kind of
power you have so you can imagine then
you can use that technology against the
masses so people who took part in those
process have had phone calls or texts
saying we know you were there do you
want to lose the following things think
twice about it so if you have that
control ultimately you kind of wonder
whether in the end these autocracies
will be able to stay in part
indefinitely so I think one of the
questions for 2023 and Beyond is it has
technology rendered dissent and unrest
and opposition obsolete is there nothing
you can do eventually ultimately if
you're a young Iranian Russian or
Chinese person if you're against that
kind of orwellian control or actually
can they find ways around it and the
Chinese protesters have been very
resourceful in getting around online
censorship and they've they've found a
way of control organizing nationally
despite this orwellian control system
that the Chinese spent billions on so I
think you know it's not a it's not a
foregone conclusion and I think it's one
of the questions about great questions
of our time is can that technology been
overturned or does it mean that these
corrupt old men are in power
indefinitely I said I suspect it depends
a little bit on uh which men are running
those technology firms as much as the
people who are on the ground and Dom
been absolutely fascinating chatting to
you what a year 2022 was thank you very
much for your time and that is
everything from this special edition of
this guy News Daily many of the topics
that we have covered you will find on
The Daily itself just go and have a
search for Sky News Daily whatever you
find your podcast we'll see you next
time
[Music]
thank you